yeah welcome to this game five minute
game and let's see some go for modern
defense barrier ah long Kings Indian
lines I hope this active looking at
least looking knight on d4 some this sum
is some well-placed
no I don't look too bad you can play a
form at at some stage all night a
five-year maybe not at five so trying to
arrest a way that cannot really take him
ever I can take but after the recap
tional night f5 looks Dukes we engine
and yeah neither five or so not very
well thought out yeah I should have just
cancelled probably or c5 also not hmm
yeah this is one additional problem
Bishop b5 since this is playable Wow
maybe
yeah maybe g4g 49 h 4 maybe i can do
that but f-for hmm kappa g4 i can take
and click queen h4 maybe this is good
yeah this is good the very shaky a
position here in the center all these
pieces are some our tides together and
it can easily lead to some sort of
overload yeah he's investing a bit of
time I understand that I would have done
the same probably oh this one this is
this is really surprising become so this
kind of structure check it's just done
is just very comfortable for black want
this one yes simply because this Bishop
only five has such a strong piece while
this Bishop is is very bad it just
points into thin air here doesn't
threaten anything ever and I can play
wiki eight yeah okay and this is
actually a decent IDM trying to prevent
rook e8 but Dirk it doesn't matter so
much I have h4 as a possible idea that
can also gain this temple so watch now
if for no h4 I can pledge from you
cannot he cannot answer with g4 then h4
is good
I can just play it simple yup just cover
this and then play Luke age 8 and try to
double on the edge file he's always tied
to the g3 porn it's very hard to play in
this position
yeah 92 was so this was a problem this
wasn't good I think before I am in
trouble yeah trying to get some play
against g6 probably check and now this
one I hope intending Queen h1 king of
two also Queen each one this looks like
a decisive a techno white resign yeah
probably it's even mate I don't know my
compounds on minus eight no mage but
minus eight is enough yeah this is this
what I played he is probably very
dubious half the computer doesn't give
give it to give give much here for white
just 0.3 you wants to advance to play
just bishop d to the thing is what made
me am I have my doubts it's led all
those pieces here if you look at all the
pieces they are all tied together I mean
look I cannot I cannot lose this I
cannot move this night because d4 is
hanging out so just let's say makes a
zero move I can never prove this because
then I lose this night this this knight
on d4 doesn't have a square I mean group
you want to city let's play this one the
computer suggestions not bad it's hard
for me to move any of those pieces it's
a this this d4 not it's nice but it
doesn't
Square to go to maybe I can play
something like that him yeah this is
probably good actually making deform a
lot more secure place now it's probably
nothing special for black but it's
certainly quite solid alright thanks for
watching